I think one of the issues that people
always point back to is balance you know
you know for most executives whether
they're female or not integrating home
and work is increasingly difficult but
particularly if you take time out of
work at a sort of critical career stage
it can be more difficult to get back and
coming at the same velocity and more
companies are thinking about having a
work pattern that's slow a fast slow
fast and allowing people to jump back
onto the bus quite quickly but it's
disappointing that we are finding that
the aspirations in the UK amongst women
are lower than they are in developing
markets I mean that's the real disparity
that is very interesting in this report
Brazil China India aspirations are far
higher than here in Britain and what
we're also seeing is in those markets
there's an awful lot more development of
women in the workplace
either mentoring or whether or not it's
more learning-based development and
perhaps we're lagging behind that and
there's a huge opportunity for UK
organisations to spend a bit more time
spotting those with potential and
putting some real development energy
behind it sort of businesses do about
this so I think the first thing is you
know the world is short of great talent
and making sure that if you recognize
that you've probably got more talent in
your own organization than you might
have thought you did is absolutely key
and then putting some real development
in behind it helping people to see that
there are small in one way to be a
leader and that they can do it in a way
that you know perhaps an overused word
but they can do it more authentically
bringing more of their own values
personality and principles to bear in
leadership roles then people might have
thought in the past one of the other
interesting darkest room is in this is
about attitudes to corporate social
responsibility among female executives
in this country we put less of a
priority on it here than the female
executives elsewhere I think corporate
social responsibility has become more
embedded it's actually a part of
leadership generally so I don't I'm not
sure we're seeing a huge gender
difference in that many more of the CEOs
that we talk to now have a real sense of
purpose about what they're trying to
achieve for organisations and actually
that sense of purpose and how to how to
actually be creative as a leader and
either route your organisation in
society or think about how to unleash
think about how to make sure that you're
connecting with the workforce not just
through you know an intellectual sort of
argument about what you should be doing
those are all becoming much more
important for people who might be trying
to transfer Morgana's ations or actually
transform the way business works do we
need more female business role models we
absolutely do need more female business
role models and and I think while the
initiative to to aim to put 30 percent
of women on boards has been a really
positive one one of perhaps the
unforeseen consequences is that it's
pulled some of the most senior women out
of organizations earlier than we might
have anticipated so there's actually
been as a reduction overall of leader of
females who are leading organizations or
at the top of organizations so less role
models now what we need to do is ensure
that we are actually looking at those
who can actually grow into those roles
and making a real positive effort to
develop them into it separately NatWest
has produced some research today which
suggests that female entrepreneurship is
on the wane does that surprise you
um no I'm not completely surprised by
that I mean again I think what we're
looking for is you know to make people
successful is not something you can do
on your own you need support you need
encouragement you need development and
you know you are seeing less of that
around generally and we're not seeing
enough of it either within companies or
within smaller businesses and there's
quite a lot of you know restrictions red
tape legislation people to go to and
helping navigate through those with the
support of others is really critical
actually to being successful